well drones have targeted at the heart
of the Russian capital's Financial
District well this is the first attack
to hit the area which houses moscow's
top companies one of the drones that
damaged the facade of a 50-story
skyscraper Victoria gatenby reports
the moment drones crashed into an office
building in moscow's financial district
having been shot down by Russia's
military
the first drone attack to hit this area
of the capital where some of Russia's
top companies have their headquarters
people in nearby apartment blocks say
they're trying to absorb what happened
my friends and I rented an apartment to
come here and unwind and at some point
we had an explosion and it was like a
wave everyone jumped and then there was
a lot of smoke and you couldn't see
anything from above You Could See Fire
Russia's defense Ministry blames Ukraine
for the attacks it says a third drone
was brought down in moscow's outskirts
fionnikovo International Airport was
closed for an hour and the airspace over
the capital was temporarily closed
Moscow is around 500 kilometers from the
border with Ukraine drone attacks deep
inside Russian territory have
intensified in recent months hitting oil
installations and even the Kremlin in
May
this attack comes several weeks into a
Ukrainian counter-offensive to take back
territory captured by Russia since the
start of the war
there's an awareness in Russia that they
are vulnerable to attacks despite
attempts by Russian media to deafen
areas and to show their repelling all
strikes in Crimea and in Russia it's no
longer possible to talk about harm
conditions in Russia
Russia says one person was injured but
such attacks raise uncomfortable
questions for Moscow who've told
Russians the government is fully in
control of what it calls its special
military operation in Ukraine
Victoria Gayton B Al Jazeera
well Daniel Hawkins has more now from
Moscow
well Moscow City certainly stands out on
moscow's landscape it's a symbol of
Russia's Financial power and wealth very
much a bustling Hub full of residential
buildings high-rise office blocks uh
private and government institutions
located there it's called the human ant
hill by locals showing just what a busy
and bustling area this is and how many
more casualties could have been uh could
have been that had the strike taken
place just a few hours later when people
were perhaps getting up and going about
their business now we understand three
drones took part in this attack one was
taken down outside of Moscow beyond the
city's limits two crashed into what's
been described as a non-residential
building in that location now the
ministry of Defense says these drones
were taken down by electronic warfare
measures but we don't know what the
targets of these drones were the area
has a lot of high profile buildings just
behind me you can see the White House
lost the seat of Russian government
you've got the Hotel Radisson Ukraine
and you've got as many as seven
government agencies located in that uh
Court of the IQ quarter of Moscow City
and Witnesses described a lot of debris
government papers and files being
scattered around quite a wide range
after that explosion showing that
perhaps some of those offices may have
been hit those images circulating on
social media we understand one person
was injured a security guard that's
according to Russian State media in this
explosion and Witnesses including some
friends that I had in Moscow City at the
time described the ground and the
building as being really shaken by this
explosion showing just how powerful it
was
Russia meanwhile says it's down to 25
Ukrainian drones over the annexed
Crimean Peninsula this is one of the
largest attacks in recent weeks in the
russian-controlled territory Ukraine
says it targeted a bridge linking Crimea
to Hassan
Russian President Vladimir Putin says
the Navy will receive 30 new ships this
year he made that announcement in Saint
Petersburg as Russia celebrates Navy day
the Kremlin says four African heads of
state are also attending after the
Russia Africa Summit wrapped up in that
City on Friday Iran has also sent a
delegation including its top Naval
official as well as several Naval
vessels